and dear fellow Scholars this is two
minute papers with Dr Carol Jonah ifahir
today we will talk about nvidia's new
products that will likely revolutionize
art medicine and even Virtual Worlds
these are the folks who make these
amazing graphics cards that chai GPT and
gpt4 are trained on but they also do so
much more so here are three new things
that really caught my eye and I hope
they will catch yours too first was
their new generative AI solution they
call Picasso what does it generate it
takes a piece of text and generates an
image okay we already know about this
but it can also generate a video
normally I would say this is going to be
huge but it already is you see Runway is
already making use of nvidia's tools for
amazing video editing magic it provides
a holistic solution where we can find
the boundaries of a person in a video
and move him but only him change the
background use video in painting to get
rid of unwanted details or even perform
video to video Transformations and give
us a complete makeover with just one
text brand this is going to
revolutionize filmmaking loving it also
Picasso can make sure that these systems
are only trained safely on data that we
have copyrighted to but wait hold on to
your papers fellow Scholars because from
a piece of text it can also render
something else and that is creating 3D
models oh yes now we're talking don't
forget Nvidia also says the graphics
cards that run today's games and
anything that includes virtual world for
instance here with Omniverse we can
breathe live into this virtual world by
only using our imagination and of course
some text Brands to make them a reality
second their Omniverse system is now so
powerful that using it we can build a
virtual Factory and simulate how it will
work before building the real factory
Technologies like this will only become
more important as the USA is looking to
build a ton of cheap fabrication
facilities domestically in the near
future what's more Amazon is already
using these autonomous self-driving
robots in a warehouse so that they can
move these boxes around safely and
efficiently but before they build these
they are using these tools to simulate
what such a warehouse should look like
and how it should work and now you see
something at work that is very close to
my heart and that is light transport
simulations or in other words the
rendering of these videos these are now
so accurate that we can see in advance
what our little world and our little
robots will look like in reality before
we build them in such a system we can
place the sensors and design their
geometry according to our wishes and of
course you fellow Scholars know that I
cannot resist the temptation that they
can also simulate not only what things
look like but what they should behave
like yes that means fluid simulations a
fire simulation or even other kinds of
physics simulations as well many of
which can run in real time these systems
are now good enough to test self-driving
cars in a virtual world and train them
there before deploying them into the
real world technological advancement is
accelerating at a rapid pace and just
imagine what good this could do and in
general just think about it we are
simulating reality and steer the
simulation into one particular reality
that we are looking for
how cool is that what a time to be alive
third they also launched bionimo a
system that is aimed to save human lives
yes this is a new AI based drug
Discovery service it includes the
amazing Alpha fault from deepmind and a
lot of other systems Pro to gpt2 a
language model for Designing proteins
and systems for molecule generation
remember that whenever we talked about
medical papers I always say that this is
an important step towards drug Discovery
but that is a long long journey and this
is finally A system that runs super fast
and helps scientists with several
elements of this journey at the same
time and once again here it is not the
AI that discovers the drugs the AI is
there to help humans do their work a lot
better so what do you think what would
you use these tools for let me know in
the comments below if you are looking
for inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda
now offers the best prices in the world
for GPU Cloud compute no commitment or
negotiation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with Lambda GPU Cloud you
can get on-demand a100 instances for
1.10 per hour versus 4.10 per hour with
AWS that's 73 savings did I mention they
also offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like apple
MIT and Caltech in using Lambda Cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lambdalabs.com papers to
sign up for one of their amazing GPU
instances today thanks for watching and
for your support and I'll see you next
time